I'll tell you what I'm wishing I brought
some better shoes
so let me say how I'd describe it so
there's back in the 1700s they found
this black rock here in the moor and
while they were looking for coal and
feldspar and other stuff and it was
really heavy and they didn't know what
was going on
so they gave it to a bunch of scientists
and they did all sorts of chemistry
mumbo-jumbo stuff and they extracted
something from it they'd never seen
before
got called yttrium in the end years and
years later they started looking at it
some more some of the numbers weren't
quite adding up they said actually this
is just a shade heavier or shade lighter
than it's supposed to be so they put it
back in the lab did a whole bunch of
other chemistry stuff to her and they
found out there were three other
elements mixed in as well that they'd
also never seen before and that's where
we get opium terbium and it terbium and
that's pretty much the history of you to
be mine yes it's a very moving time
going to see the mine in a lot of
history and being in the same place of
the people that discovered the elements
came it's been very good so now back in
the wagon
so way back so it is a very very cold
place in in Sweden it's about minus 1
degrees and over there there's a very
large castle that castles a museum and
it's a museum for the area and we're
hoping to find a little bit of a I
suppose a monument to the mine you know
where all of these elements are found
and where we've seen the history of some
of the chemistry that we've spoken about
now and that's only open during the week
and today is actually Saturday so we've
actually spoken to the lady that looks
after the castle and she's going to open
it especially for a periodic table
special oh it's just taxi on the side so
we hope this is our chauffeur
hi thanks for seeing us today
nice thank you actually the first
fortress was built here even now fifteen
hundred and forty-four
now we are unsigned in this little mean
exhibition about this famous place at
real sorrow it's an island not far away
from here in this room here there's two
rooms we tell little about this strange
thing about that place we are now here
at the fortress this little island here
VAX Holmen and if we take a look at the
map over here you find the other island
he'll Cornelia Sarah and yes where we
see it where it's pointed here this is
the place where they had the mine yes
well a lot of people well most people
interested in in the chemist and
something they are they know about this
so my colleague Eric if he thought that
well we should build a little little
room to tell people about this so in the
summer time the door is always open here
so you can always come in them and take
a little look also have heard that this
that first I mostly thought it was a
joke but it actually is true they say
that the nobel prize in chemistry
chemistry so they come out when they
come to Sweden and they want to visit
the place it to be really well here you
can see some photos from the time they
had the mine there well I think the
people living at the rear sorry they
often take people there too to talk
about this and and so prior to the
heritage yes I think it's but perhaps
not so well-known but but the the people
that knows it are very interested you
can say yeah so we see atrium ytterbium
terbium and erbium for the samples which
originated and were originally found in
the mine here near Vaxholm gadolinite
which is this very dark very very dark
black mineral it was mistaken for coal
originally and it was but it was very
very heavy much much heavier than than
coal which is basically a carbonaceous
material so when Carl axel Arrhenius
picked this up
could see that it wasn't normal : he
sent it away to be analyzed and for the
extractions to be carried out so this
this type of rock was really where all
of this chemistry started all those
years ago in 1787 and as a result we
found all these other bad boys here yeah
each summer we must keep inside you see
yeah we have got some how do you say
that in English dust oh I think it's
more than that actually yes yeah 1944
okay so there's a lot of history here as
oh yes